Sunonny Faz, feed him to the Muslims. I
hope they cut off his head.
>> Uh, so I'm trying to understand this
absolute this intellectual
with a squeaky voice who is
accused of being a closet gay. Are you
gay?
>> I want to invite you to add [music]
something powerful to your jar list.
>> We're on a mission
>> to teach tens of thousands of people
around the world
>> how to pray salah properly.
>> Just imagine this. You help someone
learn with how to pray,
>> how to recite surah faty,
>> every
prayer for the rest of their lives,
>> you share in a reward.
>> When they teach their children
>> and their children's children,
>> the reward continues for you. For just
£100,
>> you can help teach 20 to 60 people like
you. Learn salah. Donate today and earn
rewards that never stop.
To brothers and sisters and dear
friends, hope you guys are well
inshallah. So this is a video that was
sent to me. Subhan Allah from brother
Tony Faz asking for us to make dua for
him to Allah to protect him. Uh why?
Because there's this guy called Nick
Fuentes, whatever his name is. Um he
looks like a he looks a bit like I'm not
going to lie, he he he seems like an
anti-semitic individual in the in the
literal sense. Not in the sense where
you know you hating Israel makes I think
literal sense. Okay. I know they I think
it's in his number form as well. He also
be like Ben Shapiro you know it might be
his cousin or something for that matter.
We don't want to know. Uh but these
seems and also there's rumors about him
being a closet gay. He might be gay. Are
you gay? The question was are you gay?
Now why am I saying this? He made this
post this video about sonif asking him
to be decapitated. Let's watch it for
ourel inshallah and let's see what this
squeaky little white boy had to say
about this.
>> Sonny faz feed him to the Muslims. I
hope they cut off his head.
Sunny Faz, feed him to the Saudis. Feed
him. I I want them to give get him like
Jamal Kosigible.
But Sneo, pray for Sneo.
He's got to come back.
Otherwise,
it's going to be like Kingdom of Heaven.
It's going to be like that movie.
But anyway, no, we we love Sneo. Sunny
Faz
race trader. You turned your back on
your own people. But Sneak,
we got to return.
>> Okay, one second. So, Subhan Allah, I
don't understand. So, Sneo, he's like
Sneo, he wouldn't deem Sneo to be an
actual American citizen. Yeah. He deems
Sony Faz to be even though Son has got
Italian roots. So, I don't understand.
So, Son, he wants to totally get rid of
him, saying that he should be
decapitated by uh the Muslims. Um why
would any Muslim for that matter do that
anyways? for example, Muslims um don't
do that to non-Muslims, let alone do it
to their own brothers, unless they're
absolutely deluded and deranged. Uh so
I'm trying to understand this absolute
this intellectual with a
squeaky voice who is accused of being a
closet gay. Um he's he promotes the far
right and the far right obviously, you
know, talk about the um the the what's
it called? The Aryan, you know, this is
what they believe this this genetically
they are the ones at the top and subhan
Allah, they talk about the white race
being replaced. My friend Nick Fentes,
why are you not having more children?
Why you not have Where's your wife? No,
I don't care about I'm just asking,
where is your wife? Where's your kids,
bro? Why are you not married? Yes. Why?
Why are you one of those weird guys who
have no females in their life, you know?
And and look, if you want to be gay, you
can be gay. You know, as somebody I
mean, there's that comedian who comes
and asks, you know, why are you gay? I
don't care about that. The question is
this. You want to promote this white
supremacy and all that kind of stuff.
But then again, when it comes to this
stuff, but my friend, where is your
children? Where where are you populating
the earth with white people? Huh? Where
is this? Yes, you're an Islamophobe.
You're an actual anti-semite,
anti-semitic. I'm not talking about in a
sense where, you know, I'll get called
anti-semitic being against Israel and
Zionism, not Jews. I have many Jewish uh
friends that I know. I've actually been
I've been to the synagogue with Aaron
and he's told me about, you know, the
rules that they follow, etc. So, subhan
Allah, um the matter is very clear. And
not only that, Sonifas. Who's Sonif?
Sonifas is a brother. Alhamdulillah, who
is true to his cause, unlike Andrew Tate
and also Sneo, which I'm going actually
going to be seeing both of them in
tomorrow or the next day. Alhamdulillah,
we're going to do a podcast together.
I'm going to invite him to the Let's
Play game show. Alhamdulillah, beautiful
brothers who have thrown truly and look
how Allah works in mysterious ways. Both
of them may have played a not. But
Andrew tape playing a role in them
coming to Islam and alhamdulillah look
how Allah works in miraculous ways where
we know where Andrew tape direction he's
going. You know, he's become he was
against the matrix. He became the
matrix. He is the matrix now. Yeah.
Okay. He's got Israeli workers for him
in Israel out of all the countries in
the world. And alhamdulillah that I saw
something really beautiful about Sony FS
that I wanted to share with you guys and
you can watch for yourself. Watch what
he does. Uh when police officers come at
New York center uh New York City uh Time
Square to tell them to pack their uh
table if they don't have permission to
do daer. Look what he's done. He does
something really remarkable. Uh and I
really admire him for that.
>> Do you guys have a permit or permission
to have a table here?
>> Oh, we're not selling anything.
>> It doesn't matter. I could give you a
ticket. It's $500. I'm just coming here
and talking to you instead.
>> Okay. Can you just give us a ticket?
>> No, but you could go.
>> Can we stay here and just get a ticket?
>> Yes.
>> All right. I got it.
>> Did you see that? Subhan Allah. He and
and you can see sincerity. Sonifas
sneaker. You can see that they believe.
They're not just by word. That's what
Allah says in the Quran. Don't say
you're going to say I'm a Muslim and not
be tested. You will be tested and trial.
He said I will pay the $500 ticket. I
mean I'll be honest with you. I'm in the
da. I mean it might you might call it a
financial thing. Maybe maybe he has more
money than I do. I mean I might be like
you know what man let's you know if it's
a really important place to do da I mean
I might move the da table some. I might
say you know what guys maybe maybe let's
go in the woods like you know I might
say guys let's move table some daif no
bro I'll pay the ticket I'm going to do
my dawa. So I applaud him that I've been
in the da for 13 years you know I'll be
thinking about plan B like you know
maybe let's move across the road or
somewhere and whatever it is for that
matter. He was like no I'll pay the $500
and alhamdulillah that is admirable.
Okay. Or admirable should we say. Yeah.
Alhamdulillah. And Nick Fes says, "Huh,
challenge you to a debate. You are a
coward. You cannot debate it. Okay, you
are intellectually bankrupt. You're a
stubbian Muhammad would say or a
pussanous weasel, which I would also say
don't you dareh talk about our brother's
son or sneaker for that matter." Okay,
we have got their backs. Alhamdulillah.
Cuz they are brothers. They are
believers. And you believe your
worldview is what? Blood is thicker than
water. You're talking about genealogy
and DNA and white supremacy whatever or
race seriously. Yeah. Okay. You would
say probably race is thicker than blood.
We say iman faith is ficker and blood.
We as believers, as Muslims, we are one
unit and one brotherhood. And that's the
reason why why we're at our weakest that
you're terrified of us, bro. And sneak
home. May Allah preserve them and make
them a means that they bring people
close to Islam. And the brother till
next time. Asalam alalaykum brothers and
sisters. Don't forget to support the
cause of teaching people how to pray
salah. sisters a simple donation of 100
pounds can help teach 20 to 60 people to
learn how to do to learn how to do salah
and even learn the link is there donate
nowam
keep an eye of our podcast are coming up
with sneif
and the whole team and most as well
goodbye